[Applause]
okay okay okay okay okay
put your shirts back on
it's disgusting and we're a bra Miss
it's Friday so you know what that means
let's welcome tonight's guest he's the
tastiest snack from Britain since
crumpets and crisps oh is that the
killer interview with Piers Morgan
available now on Fox Nation Piers Morgan
yeah
as a Miss Universe judge she's an expert
on dumb questions which makes her the
perfect guest host of The Hoop chat
Emily Austin
whether it's NFL stars or me she's
talking to a man in a jockstrap oh
something Michelle Tafoya podcast
Michelle Tafoya
and finally he's so dreamy you can trace
him to the bedroom HOSA Fox News at
night Trace Gallagher
[Applause]
all right it's my uh game day Jersey you
see GG pretty cool I know you can order
them at Fox Nation
okay before we get to some new stories
let's do this
Greg's leftovers
yeah it's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading these
so if they suck will waterboard Joe
Mackey and then feed his body to hyenas
[Laughter]
all right here we go God help me during
a hearing in the Mexican Congress UFO
experts display two supposed non-human
alien corpses I say big deal we have
those in our Congress too
[Applause]
for that Smuckers Smuckers is buying
snack cakes maker Hostess Brands in a
deal worth 5.6 billion but only after
Hostess rejected a matching offer from
another buyer
[Laughter]
[Applause]
people are sick Hunter Biden has been
indicted on federal gun charges for
allegedly lying to a gun dealer on a
form when buying a revolver in 2018.
legal experts are questioning his
defense strategy which is quote I needed
it to protect my cocaine
[Laughter]
doesn't
tennis star Novak Djokovic I think I
said that right he won the U.S open
despite refusing the shot promoted by
the event's sponsor moderna
wow
players who did get the vaccine must be
rolling in their graves
[Laughter]
[Applause]
credit Virginia politician Susanna
Gibson gained National Fame after
someone leaked videos of her Live Sex
Shows and viewers were encouraged to tip
uh the nurse practitioner even if they
covered the 30 copay
that's good a bride fessed up to
secretly over feeding her sisters to
make herself look thinner at her wedding
she knew she had them when she asked if
they wanted chicken or fish and they
replied yes
but uh Brad realized her plan went too
far when her sister caught the bouquet
then ate it
Jesse Smollett was back in court
appealing his conviction for faking a
racist homophobic attack against himself
he was originally sentenced to 150 days
in jail 30 months probation and a
macrame class so he can make a more
convincing news
in Illinois two biological males
recently crushed the competition in
women's cycling races although they
later tested positive for Peds which is
performance enhancing dongs
[Laughter]
he Jets and Bill
Rogers left the game with a
season-ending injury when asked how he
felt Roger said great since now I don't
have to play for the Jets
[Applause]
poor guy former Teen Idol Donnie Osmond
says he's never once cursed is an entire
life although he was tempted that time
he hit his thumb with a hammer while
stepping on a rake and listening to
Geraldo
[Applause]
Subway restaurants in Pakistan are now
promoting half-sized Subs it's the first
time in history of the world that
anybody has bragged about a three-incher
[Laughter]
according to a new book Elon Musk hates
Donald Trump this after Trump claims
he's never been more popular among
African Americans
laughs
and finally
a new money-saving trend shows that
adults are now ordering food off kids
menus Trend I've been doing that for
years said one man
[Applause]
all right
let's do some news okay so did Dove soap
just inherit the plight of our poor
friends over at Bud Light you have a
hate crime hoaxer spreads fat love and
still scores the deal with Dove Dove
soap has partnered with BLM activist
Dana Bryant zaina Bryant to raise
awareness about so-called fat liberation
yeah get a load of her
zaina Bryant ironically no relation to
Lane
true she could only enter like the
Kool-Aid Man
and let's face it it is kind of weird
she partnered with this Dove bar and not
this one
thank you
but once again here you have another
massive company who didn't vet their
spokespeople preferring instead to go
woke back in 2020 Bryant tried to
destroy the life of a white college
student by falsely accusing her of
racism Brian claimed the girl threatened
to run over George Floyd protesters and
called them speed bumps there was no
evidence that ever happened and Brian
later had to admit that she may have
misheard it but at least harassing a
complete stranger made her feel as good
as eating four cheesecakes on the toilet
oh my God
and now calls for a boycott of Dove
products are growing louder with
conservatives taking to social media and
posting pictures of Dove soap in the
trash Kid Rock won't be buying Dove or
any soap for that matter
yeah it's Bud Light all over again
though this time with a better tasting
product
yeah
a huge corporation groveling and virtue
signaling to Liberal activists who hate
you but unlike Bud Light where Dylan
Mulvaney was slim enough she could still
see her own penis
this time doves going after the obese
now hear me out they hire an obese woman
to Hawk their soap I guess because more
fat equals more surface area and more
surface area equals more soap and more
soap equals more profits
and my haters say all I am is a pretty
face
on the other hand maybe Bryant is the
perfect role model for the brand if you
spell it r-o-l-l oh gosh oh
Piers I don't care
and you shouldn't care I don't why
should we care about hurting her
feelings exactly somebody who went out
of her way to destroy a young female
student's life she harassed her she
campaigned against her she tried to
basically cancel her from any civilized
society and what's her reward rather
when she was caught being a liar she
gets canceled no no no somebody at dub
who are these people yes who are these
people right it's like the one at
Gillette he said you know what we're
going to do we have a new Campaign which
is rather than saluting men for being
great it's going to say all men are
Harvey Weinstein till they prove
otherwise nine billion off the bottom
line and then you go to Bud Light and
Dylan Mulvaney and that Fiasco and then
someone at Dove has gone that really
works for those companies what we're
going to do is find the single most
unlikable yeah on unpersonable right
unconscionable human being in America
and we're going to make that person the
face of our soap and just purely by the
by what is fat Liberation
good point it's called removing your
belt right this whole this whole
celebration of being gigantic yeah it's
ridiculous so yeah on every level this
is now going to get the reward it
deserves which is the sales of Dove soap
are going to collapse and they're going
to wonder why the answer is because they
have woes themselves into Total Carnage
and they deserve all that they get yeah
you know if that acceptance is a straw
man argument because no one is
condemning fat people to death but
promoting obesity is is actually
promoting death if you celebrate morbid
obesity what you're saying is we think
it's good that people are going to die
yeah it just makes you some of the
sickest people in America yeah obesity
is now a positive lifestyle Choice Emily
being homely and attractive like you are
are you mad
are you mad that Dove is not doing ugly
positive soap commercials
I'm mad that my mom told me when I was
16 that I should start watching my
weight because I'd have a lot more brand
deals if I had an apparently so I don't
know like you said what is fat
Liberation if Dove actually gave a damn
about that they would give people free
gym memberships like I don't understand
what the motive is behind showing people
like hey this is healthy this is good
and this this is what you should
aspire to be yeah absolutely not I don't
blame people for throwing stuff in the
garbage because that's frightening to
promote this as a beauty standard no
yeah like it's definitely not yeah it's
a promoting wokism over like life
expectancy so Michelle do you think this
is just pure woke virtue signaling
or some kind of calculated economic
decision because obese people use more
soap
that in my masters of business
drop that in oh yeah thank you
little Flex Flex uh I'm just glad we get
to use the word fat again because I
thought we weren't allowed to use the
word fat but clearly we are as long as
we use it with the term Liberation now
here's my problem with this if this is
just slicing and dicing all of us more
so now not only are you a color you are
a gender you are a pronoun and now
you're a size yes and that allows you to
become a minority which allows you to
ask for victimhood treatment right so
that's what this is listen
fat Liberation is not a thing you are I
haven't seen anyone who is obese be
denied Liberties right as we know them
right so if you need fat Liberation it's
in here have your own inner Citadel in
which you own everything about yourself
that you're fat that you're whatever you
are and live with that and if anyone
else has a problem with it that's on
them not on you so this fat Liberation
stuff is just another woke Ploy and it's
yes amen
Trey's I have a study here that says
that according to recent research Trace
Gallagher is the sexiest man alive
study yes listen the whole concept of
this Dove thing is it doesn't quite have
the impact for me that Bud Light had you
know you'd walk into the market and you
see Bud Light cases stacked up to the
ceiling yeah people like I'm not buying
that stuff I mean boycotting Dove kind
of like boycotting handy wipes right who
who notices right it's not like you see
the dove
I never use them on my hand you never
right oh God
[Laughter]
they're not the quicker picker upper
right that's well that's something else
no that's the quicker picker that's what
you ate Swiffer the quicker whiffer
picker upper but it just doesn't have
the same you know the resonance that the
Bud Light thing had because everybody
Bud Light was kind of the number one
light uh but a light beer brand and and
Dove
yeah you know what yeah I gotta go but
the interesting thing peers is it it's
like I doubt that all the dove
executives are obese so it's kind of
like rich rich liberals who tell the
poor how Noble it is to be poor so you
have these rich skin any Executives
telling you how Noble it is to embrace
the worst risk factor for everything
from covid to heart disease to diabetes
and they think that they're helping
tomorrow night I'm going to be in
Reading Pennsylvania for the next stop
on my book tour and there's a few
tickets still available I got some
special guests including shalu Jamie
lissout Jim Norton Joe Mackey Nick
depaolo go to gutfeld.com for Ticket
info up hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else